Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在进行、非常令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断、顺其自然的收入，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢“通往定期收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge），这是由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details.
这些原则都同样适用于你。挑战赛中还有由丽莎本人直接送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战赛，你还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士进行一对一教练辅导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。
Right, let's get on with today's episode. Hi, welcome along to today's episode where I am talking to Dr. Liz Gregory, who is a consultant clinical psychologist who has just retired. We are discussing all things psychology, how the career has changed over time, what her clinical passions have been. We also cover her top tips for aspiring psychologists, as well as thinking about navigating work whilst struggling with a physical health diagnosis and all that that entails. Hope you find it so useful. Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified
好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。嗨，欢迎收看今天的节目，在这期节目中，我采访了刚刚退休的顾问临床心理学家莉兹·格雷戈里（Dr. Liz Gregory）博士。我们探讨了心理学的一切，包括这份职业随时间的变化，以及她过去的临床热忱。我们还涵盖了她给有志成为心理学家的朋友们提供的顶级建议，同时也思考了如何在与身体健康诊断作斗争的同时驾驭工作，以及这其中所涉及的一切。希望你会觉得这非常有用。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客伴你左右，你将迈向获得专业资格的道路
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I love what we can learn about the psychology profession and about ourselves from people at different stages of the journey. It's my absolute pleasure to chat with our guest for today's episode, Dr. Liz Gregory. I hope you'll find it useful and I look forward to catching up with you on the other side. If you enjoy this episode, please do subscribe if you're watching on YouTube, like and comment. And if you are listening on podcast, for example, Spotify or Apple, please do rate and review.
欢迎来到玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我非常喜欢从处于旅程不同阶段的人们身上了解心理学专业以及我们自己。非常荣幸能与我们今天的节目嘉宾莉兹·格雷戈里博士交谈。希望你会觉得它有用，我也期待在节目结束后与你交流。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你在 YouTube 上观看，请务必订阅、点赞和评论；如果你在播客平台收听（例如 Spotify 或 Apple），请务必评分和评论。
Hi, just want to welcome our guest for today, Dr. Liz Gregory. Hi, Liz. Hi, really nice to be here. Thank you for the invitation. Oh, thank you for saying yes. So you caught my eye on Twitter because you were celebrating your retirement from being a consultant clinical psychologist weren't you? That's right yeah I retired last week after 32 years in the NHS and 27 years in One Health Board and 21 years as Joint Head of Child and Family Psychology Services there in Gwent. Amazing well done to you and I'm sure that so many people both clients and staff alike have benefited so richly from that real real dedication to your work so thank you on their behalf I'm sure they've also
嗨，让我们欢迎今天的嘉宾莉兹·格雷戈里博士。嗨，莉兹。嗨，很高兴来到这里。谢谢你的邀请。哦，谢谢你答应。我在推特上注意到你，因为你在庆祝自己从顾问临床心理学家的岗位上退休，对吧？是的，没错，我上周退休了，在 NHS（国民健康体系）工作了 32 年，在同一个健康委员会工作了 27 年，并在格温特（Gwent）担任儿童和家庭心理学服务联合负责人 21 年。太棒了，为你点赞。我确信，无论是来访者还是员工，都从你对工作真正真正的奉献中受益匪浅，所以我要代表他们向你表示感谢。我确信他们也
said thank you to you in in your retirement cards and things as well yeah it was a it was a really lovely event and it was a particularly poignant event because I've spent the last seven months actually being treated for breast cancer so to return and retire and to have all of that acknowledgement having to really put some distance between myself and work in order just to get on with the job in hand which was obviously putting my health first made it particularly yeah poignant I would say and very different to how I'd anticipated it. Yeah, absolutely. I hope that you are in better health now. Yeah, absolutely. I've come to the end of my treatment and I've rung the bell, which is the
在你的退休卡片之类的小卡片上对你表达了谢意。是的，这是一个非常温馨的活动，也是一个特别令人心酸的活动，因为在过去的七个月里，我实际上一直在接受乳腺癌的治疗。所以回到岗位然后退休，并且在经历这一切认可之前，我真的必须让自己和工作保持一段距离，以便专注于手头的事情，这显然是将我的健康放在首位，这使得这一切特别……怎么说呢，令人心酸，也和我之前预期的非常不同。是的，完全是这样。我希望你现在身体健康状况好多了。是的，绝对是的。我已经完成了治疗，并敲响了铜钟，这是
the kind of punctuation of treatment in cancer services it's always a tricky one because I think once you've had cancer you never actually fully believe that you're over it and I've got my first milestone scan in August so I'm obviously you know anticipating that but as far as the treatment has gone it's gone as well as it could so I'm keeping everything crossed. Amazing I'm so pleased for you and even when I hear you and others say you know I've rung the bell gosh it really gets my feels you know it's massive isn't it it's so significant. It is it's a really tricky one and I you know I was a bit ambivalent about it if I'm honest for lots and lots of reasons I think firstly because
癌症治疗服务中的一种标志。这总是很微妙的，因为我认为一旦你得过癌症，你就永远不会真正完全相信你已经战胜了它。我将在八月份迎来我的第一个阶段性扫描，所以我显然在期待着这一点。但就治疗而言，它进展得和预期一样顺利，所以我祈祷一切顺利。太棒了，我为你感到高兴。甚至当我听到你和其他人说“我敲钟了”时，天哪，我的情感真的被触动了，这太重大了，不是吗？太有意义了。确实如此，这是一个非常微妙的情况。说实话，我对此有点矛盾，原因有很多。我想首先因为
as I say you never quite feel it's over, I never quite know how it feels for the other people in the waiting area who may, you know, be a long way from that or may actually not be able to do that. So that's always a bit difficult. But it also felt like an important thing to do for my family who've been supporting me. And just to, you know you know as I say it's a punctuation and it marks a change of phase is how I see it rather than a woohoo it's all over I you know I don't quite see it like that. Yeah so it might be that it feels more of a rite of passage for your family but I love that you're so mindful of what others around you you know might make of that well once a psychologist yeah but I have worked really hard actually at trying to put myself first through this journey and you know obviously
正如我所说，你永远不会觉得它完全结束了。我永远不知道候诊室里的其他人会有什么感觉，他们可能离那个阶段还很远，或者实际上根本无法做到这一点。所以这总是有点困难。但对于一直支持我的家人来说，这也觉得是一件重要的事情要做。而且正如我所说，这就像是一个标点符号，它标志着一个阶段的转变，我是这么看的，而不是那种“哇哦，全结束了”的感觉，我……我并不完全这么看。是的，所以对你的家人来说，这可能更像是一个成年礼，但我喜欢你如此体谅周围其他人可能会对之作出的反应……好吧，曾经是心理学家嘛！是的，但我确实在这次旅程中非常努力地尝试把自我放在首位。你知道的，
finishing work in order to concentrate on treatment was was big for me because I've not had a period of sickness as far as I can remember at all so it was quite a big step but a really really important one. Yeah and I guess there's still knowing that we're allowed to be mindful and really pleased that our own health has has you know had a great outcome whilst also being moved by the distress of others you know it's that mutual exclusivity isn't it you know you're allowed to have one and the other absolutely absolutely and cancer has been a real challenge for that one I think so tell me a little bit if you can about your experience of being treated by the NHS rather than working within it yeah I mean it's it's been phenomenal I have to say and I think um you know I have had a bit of
为了专注于治疗而结束工作对我来说是一件大事，因为据我所能记住的，我从来没有过生病休假的时期。所以这真的是很大的一步，但也是非常非常重要的一步。是的，我想依然要知道，我们被允许去关注并由衷高兴于我们自身的健康取得了极好的结果，同时也为他人的痛苦所感动。你知道，这是那种互不排斥的关系，不是吗？你可以同时拥有这两点。绝对是这样。在这方面，癌症确实是一个真正的挑战。所以，如果你能的话，跟我讲讲你作为 NHS 治疗对象而不是工作人员的体验。是的，我的意思是，这真是太棒了，我必须这么说。而且我认为，
private treatment along the way as well because my husband happens to have private care but it is it's quite interchangeable when it comes to cancer and I think um you know every interaction I've had with every member of staff has been just incredible. And that's not always the case. I know that. I'm fully aware of that. But I can genuinely say that from my personal experience. And I guess I'm very grateful for that at a time when I needed it most. And just the competence and the kindness and I think the reassurance that you're in this system and we know what we're doing and
一路上我也接受过一些私人治疗碰巧我丈夫有私人医疗保险。但在癌症治疗方面，这些其实是相当互换的。我认为，我与每一位员工的每一次互动都简直不可思议。事实并非总是如此，我知道这一点，我对此完全清楚。但我可以真诚地说，从我个人的经历来看确实如此。我想我很感激在最需要的时候能有这样的经历。那种能力、善良，以及那种“你在这个系统中，我们知道自己在做什么”的保证，
you're going to go through this this this and this and um you know it's it's just been terribly straightforward it's been grueling I'm not going to underestimate that at all and I've had some really um tricky experiences so when I had my first chemotherapy I had a neutropenic sepsis response so had to be admitted very urgently but again all part of what they see all part of what they can anticipate and all part of what they're geared up to address so it really has been pretty spectacular I have to say. I'm delighted that you found that to be the case. I really am. And that you've, you know, got good stuff to say. And you know, you've had a good experience and a great outcome. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. Can we think a little bit about your career and how that's
“你将经历这个、这个、这个还有这个”，这真是非常直截了当。当然，这个过程也很折磨人，我一点也不会低估这一点，我确实经历了一些非常棘手的情况。比如当我第一次化疗时，我出现了中性粒细胞减少性脓毒症反应，所以必须非常紧急地入院。但这也同样是他们所能看到的、能够预期的、以及他们全副武装去应对的一部分。所以我必须说，这真的是相当惊艳。我很高兴你发现情况确实如此，真的很高兴。而且你也有很好的事情可以说，并且你拥有很好的体验和极佳的结果。是的，绝对的，绝对的。我们能聊聊你的职业生涯以及它对你来说是怎样的吗？那么，你是何时、什么时候开始决定自己可能想成为一名临床心理学家的？
been for you? So when did you, when did you start deciding that you might want to be a clinical psychologist it's a very long time ago I have to say so I did my undergraduate degree and that was a four-year degree in psychology in Cardiff and I chose psychology I would say because I didn't know what else to do and I was okay at the sciences and I was okay at the arts so it was it kind of felt like a good combination type degree and I kind of went into it and chose a degree with a year in industry or a year a placement opportunity really to help me think about what on earth I was going to do and I did my year in industry in HR and it really served a great purpose because it was, you know, a fantastic experience. But I knew it wasn't for me. But I was also I think I was the first in my family to go to university.
这是一个很久以前的故事了，我必须得说。我读的是本科，那是卡迪夫大学（Cardiff）为期四年的心理学学位。我选择心理学，可以说是当时不知道还能做些什么，我的理科还行，文科也还行，所以这感觉像是一个结合得很好的学位。我选择这个学位时包含了一年的行业实习期或实习机会，这真的帮助我思考我到底要去做什么。我在人力资源部门（HR）度过了我的一年实习期，它确实起到了很好的作用，因为那是一段美妙的经历。
Didn't see myself as particularly academic at all. And so really wrote myself off the clinical path, which even then was, you know, pretty tough in terms of competitiveness and who puts themselves through that. So I felt that wasn't for me, but I honestly didn't know what else I was going to do. Other than it wasn't going to be HR. No disrespect to that at all, but it just wasn't a good fit for me. And so I worked for a housing association for adults with learning disabilities. And I think that really introduced me into the world of obviously vulnerable groups, but also empowerment and positive choice and change. And that was very much at the time when the hospitals were closing down and adults were going out into the community. And I just absolutely loved it. And then I applied for a job as a data input clerk at
但我知道那不适合我。不过我想我也是家族中第一个上大学的人。我根本不觉得自己有多学术。因此，我真的把自己从临床道路上排除了，即使在当时，就竞争激烈程度和谁会让自己经历这些而言，这条路也是相当艰难的。所以我觉得那不适合我，但我老实说也不知道除了HR之外还能做些什么。并不是对HR有任何不敬，只是它真的不适合我。因此，我为一家服务于智障成人的住房协会工作。我想这确实让我接触到了弱势群体，同时也接触到了赋权、积极的选择和改变。当时正值医院关闭、成年人融入社区的时期，我简直太喜欢这份工作了。然后我申请了一份
a hospital at the time. And it was doing research into interventions for people with learning disabilities and I think I wouldn't dare apply for an assistant psychology post at that time because again I didn't see myself as as being able and capable of doing that and pursuing that but the I didn't get the job but the person on the interview panel said there is another job. And I think you'd be really great for that. So, you know, just, I needed that confidence building incentive, I think, to take that step. And so I got a job as a psychology assistant, absolutely loved it. I mean, I, you know, I shudder now at the level of responsibility assistance were given in those days. And, and particularly in learning disability services, because I think that recruitment was know I shudder now at the level of responsibility assistants were given in those days and and particularly in learning disability services because I think that recruitment was really
当时一家医院的数据输入员工作。那是一项针对智障人士干预措施的研究。那时我根本不敢申请助理心理学家职位，因为同样地，我不觉得自己有能力去做到这一点并去追求它。但我没有得到那份工作，面试小组中的一个人说：“还有另一份工作，我认为你非常适合它。”所以，我需要那种建立自信的激励来迈出这一步。于是我得到了一份心理学助理的工作，简直太喜欢了。我的意思是，我现在回想起当年助理被赋予的责任水平，尤其是在智障服务中，真的会不寒栗。因为我认为当时的招聘……
really tough and so they would fill a gap for a qualified person with an assistant and kind of you'd be off on your own in a team and and so-called doing the job but I learned a huge amount in that job and had you know know, great fun and great support. And it gave me the confidence to apply for clinical training. So I applied. And I remember I also, you know, assumed I wouldn't get on. And I had a car that I was going to sell and travel, you know, do the kind of year round traveling around the world.
我现在回想起来，当年助理被赋予的责任水平真的让我不寒而栗，特别是在智障服务中。因为我认为招聘真的非常非常困难，所以他们会用助理来填补合格人员的空缺，而你基本上就是在团队中孤军奋战，可以说是名义上在做这份工作。但我从那份工作中学到了大量知识，收获了巨大的乐趣和极好的支持。这给了我申请临床培训的信心。于是我申请了。我记得我也曾认为自己不会被录用。我有一辆准备卖掉去旅行的汽车，打算来一次全球环球旅行。
So I felt I put myself into that position where I had a great alternative. know I wasn't going to be too disappointed and I got on and that was that was the story and it was the Plymouth course that I did my clinical training in. Amazing and that all went relatively smoothly I hope. Yeah yes I mean it is you know it's a challenging course of course it is but I would say I genuinely enjoyed it. It was a very well organized course. It was one of those courses at the time and I'm not sure if they still happen in this way where you get allocated your placement health board or trust as it was at the time. And then you go and do blocks of teaching down in Plymouth. So there was a, you know, real variety.
所以我当时把自己放在了一个拥有很棒替代方案的位置上，这样我就不会太失望。结果我被录取了，这就是故事的经过。我是在普利茅斯课程（Plymouth course）中完成临床培训的。太棒了，希望这一切都比较顺利。是的，我的意思是，这是一个具有挑战性的课程，当然是的，但我可以说我真的非常享受它。这是一门组织得非常好的课程。它是当时那种课程之一——我不确定现在是否仍然以这种方式进行——你会分派到你实习的健康委员会或当时的信托机构，然后去普利茅斯参加集中教学。所以这里面有真正的多样性。
And I suppose a bit of an escape in a different world that you could kind of have a bit of respite from one and go into the other and a bit of respite from that and go into the other. And I think that worked really well for me and suited me. And it was the first course to get the doctorate so I think there was a lot of academic pressure but I think there was a rigor to that that that I really benefited from so I remember we had to do on top of a placement case studies and research we had to do a lot of essays so one big essay per placement but also 10 short essays per placement and I think that gave me a real skill in extracting important information and putting it down and not worrying too much about it which I think has really really served me well because you know
我想这也是一种进入不同世界的逃离，你可以从一个世界中抽身去另一个世界喘口气，再从那个世界抽身去另一个世界。我认为这对我很有效，也很适合我。这是第一个获得博士学位的课程，所以我想有很大的学术压力，但我认为这种严谨性让我受益匪浅。我记得除了实习案例研究和研究之外，我们还必须写很多论文，每个实习有一个大论文，还有10个短论文。我认为这给了我一种真正的技能，即提取重要信息并将其写下来，而不用过分担心。这真的对我有很大帮助，因为你知道，
you can pour over for hours on end if you've got one essay but if you've got 10 um you've got to crack on and I think that that was really really um good training actually amazing so reducing some of that perfectionism just done let's get it passed let's go it's gonna be another one in a minute anyway absolutely yeah and also that you know giving you some real confidence in core competencies and core concepts and core research papers that, you know, that just reading them, you know, obviously you get some insight into that. But when you've actually got to pull out that information and extract it, it was good. We moaned about it all the time. Don't get me wrong. You know, but in hindsight, when when I look back that that was a good training for me particularly yeah and I think that's where a cohort can really come in isn't it you mentioned that you kind of found the compartmentalizing quite useful and I know I did
如果你只有一篇论文，你可以琢磨上好几个小时；但如果你有10篇，你就必须抓紧时间了。我认为这真的是非常非常好的训练。太棒了！所以这减少了一些完美主义，“做完就好，让我们通过吧，反正一会儿还有下一篇呢”。绝对是这样的，是的。这也给了你在核心能力、核心概念和核心论文方面的真正自信。阅读它们自然能让你对这些有所见解，但当你真正需要把这些信息提炼并提取出来时，这是很好的训练。我们一直都在抱怨，别误会我。你知道，但事后回想起来，那对我的确是一个很好的训练，特别如此。
too and our our teaching was that it was on a Monday and a Friday with placement days being Tuesday Wednesday Thursday so it felt like a really nice cushion either side to kind of do the how was your weekend, all of that jazz, and then go into placement and then come out the other side and go, well, how was it? How's your weekend? And so for me, that compartmentalising, but in a really cushioned, safe way felt really nice. Yeah, that sounds great, actually. Yeah.
我想这就是同伴群体真正发挥作用的地方，对吧？你提到你发现将生活和工作进行区隔非常有用，我知道我也是这样的。我们的教学安排在周一和周五，实习日是周二、周三、周四。所以感觉两边都有一个非常舒适的缓冲，可以聊聊“你的周末过得怎么样”之类的话题，然后去实习，接着从另一头出来说：“感觉怎么样？你的周末过得怎样？”所以对我来说，这种区隔，但又以一种非常舒适、安全的方式进行，感觉真的很不错。是的，听起来确实很棒。
So did you continue in what is what they now call intellectual disabilities but some people do say learning disabilities or did you move into a different clinical specialty once you qualified yeah my my first role was um for children um with um intellectual disabilities learning disabilities, and particularly an intensive support service for children whose behaviours were challenging to services. And yeah, that was very intensive. And I did that for a year. And then I moved to the health board where I've spent the rest of my career. So what have you been doing in health board what's your role been? Yeah well I started as a what we call a borough psychologist so there were five boroughs in our region and each region
那么，你是在现在被称为智力障碍（但有些人仍然说是学习障碍）的领域继续发展，还是在获得资格后转向了不同的临床专业？是的，我的第一个角色是为患有智力障碍、学习障碍的儿童服务的，特别是为那些行为对服务机构构成挑战的儿童提供强化支持服务。是的，那非常高强度。我做了一年。然后我搬到了健康委员会，在那里度过了我职业生涯的剩余时间。你在健康委员会都做些什么呢？你的角色是什么？
had one psychologist so we were very sparse and it was one of those you know again I think recruitment and resources were a huge factor in this but um you could start as a neuropsychologist at a very junior level but it was actually a very senior role so I guess that preceptorship and um being supported in the job and developing in the job was something that was absolutely part and parcel of of um you know, what the careers were at that time. And I absolutely loved it. It was a great service. It had fantastic values. And I loved the community that, you know, was my borough. And it was a big sense of responsibility as well in that, you know, whatever came through the door, you were the psychologist who was going to be dealing with it. So that felt huge at the time.
是的，我最初担任的是我们所说的“行政区心理学家”（borough psychologist）。我们地区有五个行政区，每个行政区有一名心理学家，所以我们的人员非常稀少。这也是招聘和资源成为其中巨大因素的例子之一。你可以在一个非常初级的水平上担任神经心理学家，但实际上这是一个非常高级的角色。所以我想那种实习期制度、在工作中获得支持并在工作中不断成长，绝对是当时职业生涯不可或缺的一部分。我非常喜欢它。那是一个很棒的服务机构，有着梦幻般的价值观。我热爱作为我管辖区的那个社区。
But I think a really good experience of kind of learning that that's OK. We've got the skills. We can apply them to whatever the dilemmas are. And kind of taking a breath and not feeling you've got to fix everything. But the skills you bring are about curiosity and understanding and taking time and being alongside and so it was a fantastic training um in in i suppose that aspect of the job as well as the huge variety um of of issues that families might present with at any one time yeah i think that's going to be really useful advice for anybody listening to this as well because the nature of this beast that we work in is that
无论什么样的人走进门，你都是将要处理这个问题的心理学家，这本身也带有巨大的责任感。所以在当时，这感觉责任重大。但我认为这也是一次非常好的体验，它让我明白“这没关系，我们有技能，我们可以将它们应用于任何困惑”。我们要深吸一口气，不要觉得自己必须解决所有问题。你带来的技能在于好奇心、理解、花时间陪伴以及给予支持。所以这在工作的那一方面，以及家庭在任何特定时间可能呈现的大量不同问题方面，都是一次极好的训练。是的，我认为这对于任何听到这话的人来说都将是非常有用的建议，因为我们所从事的这个行业的本质就是，
you're going to have many placements or many roles and you've got to be able to sort of just run with it and I know when I first qualified I thought I was going to be sort of getting kid gloves and they would be quite leisurely start but no they'd be waiting for me for months so they were keen for me to run with it and they said you are in the nicest possible way they were really nice about it but you're qualified we trust you to do this you know to go out there and do the job absolutely yeah and I think that's such an important aspect of our training that we we need the confidence to be reassured. We've been doing this for a very, very long time. And what we're bringing is those skills,
你将会有许多实习经历或许多角色，你必须能够顺应这一切。我知道我刚获得资格时，以为自己会得到温柔的对待，会有一个相当悠闲的开始。但并没有，他们已经等了我好几个月了，所以他们渴望我能迅速上手。他们用最温和的方式对我说——他们对此真的很好——“你是合格的，我们相信你能做到这一点，你知道的，去外面把工作做好吧。”绝对是这样的。我认为这是我们培训中非常重要的一面，我们需要有信心去确信：我们做这个已经很长时间了。我们带来的是这些技能，
not a magic wand, not the answer, and not the years of experience on the job that other people in the team have. And so trusting that it is about that difference that we bring, and that that's valued and valuable is a really important part of the job, I think. I think so. But I found that really empowering, actually, that they weren't saying, well, you're not quite finished yet. You know, they were saying, you know, go out there, do it, smash it. And if there's any problems, just bring them back here and we'll talk about it in supervision. Exactly. absolutely. So you must have seen your fair share of aspiring psychologists, assistant psychologists, trainee psychologists, newly
而不是魔杖，不是现成的答案，也不是团队中其他人多年积累的工作经验。所以，相信我们带来的是这种差异，并且这种差异是有价值的和珍贵的，这是工作非常重要的一部分，我认为是的。我也这么认为。但我发现这其实非常鼓舞人心，他们并没有说“嗯，你还没完全准备好”，而是说“去吧，去做，把它做好！如果有任何问题，带回这里，我们在督导中讨论。”完全正确，绝对如此。所以，在你的职业生涯中，你一定见过不少有志心理学家、助理心理学家、实习心理学家、新晋合格的心理学家。
qualified psychologists across your career. How's that been for you watching the profession change over time? Yeah, it's been fabulous. I think it's been one of the most exciting parts of the job is that um you know seeing the journey that people are on and we've often had people who've come as placement students then come back as assistants then come back as qualified staff so I just love that full circle and also that message to us as a service that we were getting it right enough that they wanted to come back and that um you know that we supported them on that journey so I've really really enjoyed that um I think the changes it's it's really tough because when you're in it you don't kind of notice the the stepwise changes and I think one of the things that we've been
看着这个行业随着时间的发展而改变，对你来说是怎样的体验？是的，太棒了。我认为这是工作中最令人兴奋的部分之一。你知道，看到人们经历的旅程，我们经常看到有人先作为实习生来，然后作为助理回来，接着又作为合格的工作人员回来。我只是太喜欢这种完整的闭环了，这也向我们传达了这样一个信息：我们的服务做得足够好，以至于他们愿意回来，而且我们在他们的旅程中支持了他们。所以我真的非常非常享受这一点。我认为这些变化……这真的很难，因为当你身处其中时，你不会注意到那种一步步的变化。我认为我们服务中一直热忱坚持的事情之一，
passionate about uh in our service is that the core values remain. So the things that I was saying 20 years ago that are important for children and families are still important for children and families. But, you know, I hope that we're a very broad church in our service and that psychology is a very broad church and that we're continuously learning and that curiosity and not thinking we've got the answer, but that we keep learning and we keep open, being open to new ideas, new ways of working, new ways of thinking. It's just part and parcel of, I think, what we've tried to promote in our service. And I think it's, I think it's absolutely vital. Yeah, and I feel passionately about that. And I feel really proud of our profession for that, that there's not an end point.
就是核心价值观保持不变。我20年前对儿童和家庭说的重要事情，对今天的儿童和家庭依然重要。但我也希望我们的服务能够兼容并蓄，心理学是一个海纳百川的领域，我们一直在不断学习；保持好奇心，不认为自己掌握了答案，而是不断学习、对新想法、新工作方式、新思维方式保持开放。我认为，这正是我们一直在服务中努力推广的精髓所在，而且我认为这绝对至关重要。是的，我对此充满热情。我为我们的行业感到无比自豪，因为这里没有终点。
And not to feel bad about what you didn't know before, that that's all part of the process. And our job is to bring the knowledge base that we have now to the difficulties that people are experiencing and see how that fits but to never think this is the answer and you need to do this in order to solve your problem so it you know it fits quite well with the evolving nature of the profession I think. I definitely shudder when I think about my first experience of offering therapy in a youth prison because I was rubbish rubbish but I was still doing the best I could with the skills and resources I had at that time and it was still
不要为自己以前不知道的事情感到糟糕，因为这都是整个过程的一部分。我们的工作是将我们现有的知识库带给人们正在经历的困难，看看它如何契合，但永远不要认为“这就是答案，你需要这样做来解决你的问题”。所以，这与不断发展的行业本质非常契合，我认为是的。当我想到我在青少年监狱提供治疗的第一次经历时，我绝对会不寒而栗，因为我当时太糟糕了、太糟糕了！但我仍然用我当时拥有的技能和资源尽了最大努力，这对接受治疗的来访者来说仍然是有用的，只是我知道现在我会做得好得多。当然，我们谁不是这样呢？
useful for the clients that were getting that it's just I know I'd do a much better job well of course and wouldn't we all and you know and I think in child psychology and as a parent you know that's the that's exactly the feeling it's like if I knew then what I know now but I didn't and I did everything with the absolute best intention and also you know I talk about the the values that endure the most powerful value I think is the power of the relationship and if you're working hard at creating relationships it doesn't matter where you are on your career trajectory that's going to be the most powerful ingredient in any therapeutic change. Yeah and I'm a parent as well I've got two young boys they are they're going to want me to say what they almost are so
在儿童心理学领域，作为父母，你知道，那种感觉正是如此：“如果我当时知道我现在知道的就好了！”但我当时并不知道，我所做的一切都出于绝对最好的意图。而且，正如我所谈论的那些经久不衰的价值观，我认为最强大的价值观是人际关系的强大力量。如果你努力建立关系，无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，这将是任何治疗改变中最强大的因素。是的，我也是个父母，我有两个年轻的男孩——他们会希望我准确说出他们的年龄——
almost 10 and almost 7 and for me one of the most important things I can do is to repair any ruptures that crop up between myself when I haven't quite lived to my values of how I want to parent, but also encouraging them to repair ruptures rather than just gloss over them, because I think that's really, really important, and we can absolutely learn to do that with clients as well, can't we, to repair any ruptures in our relationship? yeah and you know and obviously our our relationships with professions with teams with with other services it's exactly the same as that that we're on a journey together and we're open to learning and we and if if we've got it wrong then then it's absolutely our job to let people know that, but that we're open to doing differently next time. Can I hear a bit more about the core values, the things that you think are really incredibly important when working with children, young people and families?
快10岁了，快7岁了。对我来说，我能做的最重要的事情之一，就是修复我和他们之间出现的任何裂痕——当我没有完全践行我想成为什么样的父母的价值观时。同时，我也鼓励他们去修复裂痕，而不是简单地粉饰太平，因为我认为这真的非常非常重要。我们绝对可以学会与来访者一起做到这一点，不是吗？去修复我们关系中的任何裂痕。是的，而且很明显，我们与专业同行、团队和其他服务的关系也是完全一样的。我们都在共同的旅程中，对学习保持开放。如果我们做错了，绝对有责任让大家知道，但我们愿意在下次做得不同。我能再听听关于核心价值观的更多内容吗？在与儿童、年轻人及其家庭合作时，你认为哪些事情是真正极其重要的？
Yeah, I mean, I think our job as psychologists is to really promote that relational, developmental, contextual understanding of children's distress. And, you know, to kind of see that as our role, regardless of the presenting problem, those things are absolutely critical to our understanding. And obviously, from a rights-based approach, children's rights, the importance of hearing their voice, empowerment, but also, I think, the importance of their context, the family, the system around them and the vehicles for change that they have in their wider system is absolutely pivotal to our work and really kind of more significant often than children who are often in a very disempowering role and can't affect the changes that will make the difference to them. And also, most importantly, I think that every child is unique. So if you've, you know, if you've seen this before, then, you know, it's not going to be helpful to go into a situation thinking, you know, and you understand.
是的，我的意思是，我认为我们作为心理学家的工作，是真正去促进对儿童困苦的这种关系性、发展性、语境性的理解。无论呈现的问题是什么，都将其视为我们的角色，这些事情对于我们的理解绝对是至关重要的。显然，从基于权利的方法来看，儿童的权利、倾听他们声音的重要性、赋权，同时我也认为，他们的语境、家庭、周围的系统以及他们在更广泛系统中所拥有的变革动力，对我们的工作至关重要。这通常比那些往往处于极度被赋权剥夺角色、无法促成对其产生改变的儿童更为重大。而且最重要的是，我认为每个孩子都是独一无二的。所以如果你见过类似情况，那么带着“你已经懂了”的想法进入某种情况是没有帮助的。
You've got to be curious and open to understanding it from their perspective and that it's impacting them very differently to how it might have impacted somebody else and that's not to dismiss the importance of you know knowing about an area understanding it having been through that journey before but I think that all has to be in the background and you've the foreground has to be and that this is a unique child with a unique family with a unique set of circumstances and your job is to really listen and understand that and fit what you've got to offer with with the strengths of that situation for them yeah I think a really powerful question can be well how is that for you because then you're getting their unique stance aren't you absolutely absolutely lovely so thinking about career of course, you got on to being a consultant clinical psychologist. How does that work? What does that involve?
你必须保持好奇心，并乐于从他们的角度去理解，理解它对他们的影响可能与对其他人的影响截然不同。这并不是要抹杀了解某个领域、理解它、曾经经历过这段旅程的重要性，但我认为这一切都必须作为背景，而前景必须是：这是一个独特的孩子，有着独特的家庭、独特的一套环境，你的工作是真正去倾听和理解这一点，并将你所能提供的与他们所处的具体情况的优势结合起来。是的，我认为一个非常有力的问题可能是：“这对你来说是怎样的？”因为通过这，你能得到他们独特的立场，不是吗？绝对的，绝对的。太棒了。那么，回想一下你的职业生涯，你当然成为了一名顾问临床心理学家。这是如何运作的？这包含了什么？
Gosh, well, again, that was a long time ago. And I think it's fair to say that, as I say, my first job was quite brief. I was there for a year and then I joined a service that really aligned with my values and I absolutely loved the work. And the manager at the time was retiring. And so it was that dilemma of I love where I work. And there's the potential that somebody new is going to come in and change where I work or I could put my hat in the ring. And that felt like a big step for me. I was, I think I was, you know, I can't remember, I was about 33 at the time, and I was pregnant with my first child, you know, it was the most rubbish time for thinking that I might go into that leadership role. But a colleague of mine was having exactly the same dilemma and was in a similar stage of life.
天哪，好吧，这也是很久以前的事了。我想说的是，正如我所提到的，我的第一份工作相当短暂，我在那里呆了一年，然后加入了一个真正符合我价值观的服务机构，我非常热爱那里的工作。当时的经理即将退休，所以这就成了一个两难选择：我热爱我工作的地方，有可能会来一个新人改变我工作的地方，或者我可以自己把帽子扔进赛场去竞争。这对我来说感觉是一个巨大的一步。我想我当时……我不记得了，我当时大约 33 岁，怀着我的第一个孩子。对于考虑去承担那个领导角色来说，这简直是最糟糕的时期。但我的一个同事面临着完全相同的困境，处于相似的人生阶段。
In fact, she had three under the age of five. So the last thing she wanted was to be a head of child psychology. And so we had one of those tentative conversations about, well, what could we do? Could we do it together? And we came up with a plan of going um putting ourselves forward as a job share and i've been job sharing with rachel for 21 years um so i think it was it was a really gentle step uh into what is a huge can be a huge leap and to
事实上，她有三个五岁以下的孩子。所以她最不想做的事情就是成为儿童心理学负责人。于是我们进行了一次试探性的对话：“我们能做什么？我们能一起做吗？”我们想出一个计划，作为职位分担（job share）共同申请这个职位。我和雷切尔（Rachel）已经共同分担职位 21 年了。所以我想，对于一个可能成为巨大飞跃的职位来说，这是一个非常温和的切入点。
to be able to do that together with somebody and to um you know when you're feeling absolutely overwhelmed and like you're out of the depth for them to say no it's fine we're going to break it down and this is the next thing that we're going to do and for you to do exactly that for them I think really helped us in the early days um and I think that the job sharing thing was so important also in giving us confidence, courage, bravery you know when when things were getting tougher because the health service has been through all sorts of journeys along that along the way so yeah I think I think I was fortunate that that timing coincided with someone who I felt I could do the job with and that really helped what can be quite a big transition I don't know if that answers your
能够和某人一起做到这一点，当你感到完全不知所措、觉得力不从心时，对方会对你说：“不，没关系，我们会把它分解，这是我们接下来要做的事情”，而你也可以为对方做同样的事情——我认为这在早期真的对我们很有帮助。而且我认为职位分担这件事情也非常重要，它赋予了我们信心、勇气和无畏，尤其是在局势变得艰难的时候，因为卫生服务系统在这期间经历了各种各样的历程。所以，是的，我非常幸运，那个时机与一个我觉得可以一起共事的人不期而遇，这极大地帮助了我们度过这个可能相当大的转变。我不知道这是否回答了你的问题。
question it does it does and thinking about you know what a privilege and pleasure to have cultivated that depth of relationship with your colleague over these 20 years as well absolutely it's it's it's brilliant and you know there's huge sadnesses that that's come to an end but it's the sort of relationship where we're just delighted we can actually have some fun together now and not you know we've all we've had a lot of fun along the way but we can only have fun that's the only nature of our relationship now so that you've graduated exactly a different level of your relationship exactly so. So that's brilliant. But I think, in fact, it was really interesting at my retirement due, our heads of service for psychology also job share.
是的，确实回答了。想想看，在过去的20年里，与你的同事培养出如此深厚的关系，是多么荣幸和快乐的事。绝对是这样的，这太棒了。你知道，这段合作迎来终点时会有巨大的悲伤，但这也是那种关系的类型：我们只是很高兴现在能一起开开心心地玩，不再……虽然一路上我们也有很多乐趣，但现在我们可以纯粹享受快乐，这就是我们关系的本质。所以你们升级了，达到了人际关系的不同层级，完全如此。所以这太棒了。但事实上，很有趣的是，在我的退休聚会上，我们心理学服务部门的新负责人也是通过职位分担工作的。
And apparently we were the inspiration for their relationship to pursue that particular way of working. And I think it's just such a useful model for all sorts of reasons, particularly if you have children and you prefer to work part time. It means that when you're not in work, somebody else is. And I think that allows work to be more in its place, which is a huge privilege, actually, in a job like ours, which can feel all-consuming at times. Sounds like you're trailblazers and permission givers, but also, you know, everyone else, yeah, can do, they can function without you, the world can go on. Absolutely, yeah, and I think that's right, and I was very fortunate, actually, in that I had a
显然，我们是他们追寻这种特定工作方式的灵感来源。我认为这是一个非常实用的模式，原因有很多，特别是如果你有孩子并且更倾向于兼职工作的话。这意味着当你不在工作时，另一个人在工作。我认为这让工作能够更多地回归其应有的位置，这在像我们这样有时会让人感到精疲力竭的工作中，实际上是一种巨大的特权。听起来你们是开拓者和开路先锋，但同时也向所有人证明，是的，其他人也可以在没有你的情况下正常运转，世界依然在继续。绝对是的，我想确实如此。而且我很幸运，
career break during that time, and was supported to have a career break, both by my organisation, but also by my job share partner who stepped up into the role. You know, she was at a stage in her life where that felt possible. So it just gives that little bit of flexibility. And I went to Canada for two and a half years back in 2014 and I think you know for me that gave me a completely different experience and meant I came back into the role fresher with new ideas and with new energy so I think it really served a useful function at all sorts of levels. So were you working when you were in Canada or was that a career break? It was a career break my husband's work took us out there and I did look into working but you have to have a
在那期间我拥有了一段职业间断（career break），并且得到了组织以及我的职位分担搭档的支持，她站出来承担了这一角色。你知道，她当时处于人生中觉得这完全可行的阶段。所以这只是提供了一点点灵活性。我在 2014 年去过加拿大两年半。对我和我的职业生涯来说，我认为这给了我一个完全不同的体验，意味着我带着新鲜的视角、新的想法和新的能量回到了这个角色中，所以我认为它在各个层面上都发挥了非常有用的作用。所以你在加拿大时还在工作，还是那是职业间断？那是职业间断，我丈夫的工作把我们带到了那里。我也确实考虑过工作，但你必须有
particular you have to re-qualify to work in different areas of Canada and they all have different criteria and I think even my work visa meant I couldn't work in health and education because there's no gaps um that needed to be filled there in in Canada so I took it as permission not to work um but I and I kept ourselves very busy with you know making the most of that opportunity and I had young school-aged children which obviously took a bit of sorting out as well but I did volunteer and I volunteered for Roots of Empathy which is a Canadian program it's now worldwide but it's started in Canada and it brings a baby and a parent into the classroom and helps children learn about their own emotional worlds by learning about the emotional world of the baby.
特定的资格——你必须重新获得在加拿大不同地区工作的资格，而且它们都有不同的标准。我想甚至我的工作签证也意味着我不能在医疗卫生和教育领域工作，因为在加拿大那些地方没有需要填补的空缺。所以我把它当作允许自己不工作的许可，并且我们把时间安排得很满，充分利用了那个机会。当时我还有上学的小孩，这显然也需要花点心思去理顺。但我去做了志愿者，我为“同理心的根基”（Roots of Empathy）做志愿者，这是一个加拿大项目，现在已经走向世界，但它发源于加拿大。它把婴儿和父母带进课堂，通过了解婴儿的情感世界，帮助儿童了解自己的情感世界。
And it's an evidence-based intervention that reduces bullying and increases pro-social play. So I didn't quite switch off from my world, but I, you know, it was a hugely rewarding volunteer role to do and absolutely aligned to my values and it's something that I've been passionate about bringing over here to the UK and it's now in the region where I worked and it you know it's just a great program on all sorts of levels but again it really fits with what I think is important for children to experience. I haven't heard of Roots of Empathy that sounds fascinating. Yeah it's it's brilliant it's got a really good website and really great support from a whole range of areas particularly psychological and social you know neurodevelopmental
这是一个基于证据的干预措施，能够减少欺凌并增加亲社会游戏。所以我并没有完全从我的世界中抽离，但这是一个非常有回报的志愿工作，完全符合我的价值观。这也是我一直热衷于将其带回英国的项目，现在它已经在我工作过的地区落地了。在各个层面上，这都是一个非常棒的项目，而且再次强调，它非常符合我认为儿童应该体验的重要内容。我以前没听说过“同理心的根基”，听起来很迷人。是的，它太棒了。它有一个非常好的网站，并得到了各个领域的大力支持，特别是心理和社会、神经发展领域。
aspects. It's sort of building on the why love matters type approach by Sue Gerhart. Is that the right vein that I'm in? Yes. And also, you know, just the power of relationships exactly. And why, you know, how important it is to understand your own emotional world in order to understand the emotional world of others is absolutely central to it. But it's great fun as well. And obviously, the teacher has a great experience because they're able to stand back a bit. And the instructor takes that particular aspect of the class and the parent and the baby have a fantastic experience because you literally as a mum or dad walk into a classroom and 30 children just delight in your baby and the baby delights in the children and one of the most powerful things about it which really struck
方面。这有点像建立在苏·格哈特（Sue Gerhart）提出的“为什么爱重要”的方法之上。我是在这个方向吗？是的。而且，你知道，关系的强大力量确实如此。为什么，你知道，理解你自己的情感世界以理解他人的情感世界是多么重要，这是其中的绝对核心。但这也带来了巨大的乐趣。显而易见的是，老师也有很好的体验，因为他们能够退后一步。导师负责课堂上的那个特定方面，父母和婴儿都有极好的体验，因为作为爸爸或妈妈，你字面意思就是走进教室，30个孩子对你的宝宝赞叹不已，宝宝也对孩子们感到高兴，其中一个最有力量的事情真的让我
me and I'd read about it when I'd done my research on it but to see it happen in the classroom was extraordinary that the baby somehow homes in on the most vulnerable children and I think and delights in them and I think you know probably that's the unconditional regard that the baby has for anybody who shows them delight and for that child who maybe is used to being seen in a particular way or being in trouble or, you know, whatever it happens to be, to have a baby just respond and receive them and delight in them is really powerful too. It's, it's, it's really, it's a great program. Absolutely sounds yeah it sounds incredible it sounds incredible thank you for letting me know about that I'm gonna I'm gonna have a little bit of a research
感到震撼，我在做相关研究时读到过这一点，但在课堂上亲眼看到这一幕是非同寻常的，婴儿不知何故能敏锐地找到最脆弱的孩子，我想，他们会为这些孩子感到高兴，我想，这可能就是婴儿对任何向他们展现喜悦的人所抱有的无条件关注，对于那个可能习惯了以某种特定方式被看待、或者总是惹麻烦、或者不管是什么情况的孩子来说，能有一个婴儿只是做出回应、接纳他们并为他们感到高兴，这同样具有非常强大的力量。这是一个非常棒的项目。真的听起来，是的，听起来难以置信，听起来难以置信，谢谢你让我知道了这个，我打算去稍微做点研究
on that one um could you offer any advice or guidance for aspiring psychologists you think might be useful yeah I mean I think I I think if you're absolutely passionate about it, don't give up because I've seen so many psychologists take a bit of time unforgiving if it doesn't work out. So I think that's one bit of advice. I suppose the main thing I would say, and I think this is a really hard one to really trust and believe, is to be yourself, that actually, you know, that's the thing that comes across most strongly is your your passion, your internal drive about why you want to do this particular job, your your your values, you know, and not to feel that you have to be the expert at all. But as I was saying earlier, that openness and that curiosity and that continuous learning is really, really important, particularly at that trainee stage, I think. But, you know, I genuinely think it's really important throughout the whole career trajectory. Lovely. That's brilliant, helpful advice. Thank you. What's next for you,
关于那个项目的，嗯，你能为有志成为心理学家的人提供一些你认为有用的建议或指导吗？是的，我的意思是，如果你对它绝对充满热情，就不要放弃，因为我见过太多心理学家在事情不如意时给自己一些时间去释怀。所以我觉得这是建议之一。我想我要说的最主要的一点——我认为这是一个很难真正去信任和相信的观点——就是做你自己，实际上，你知道，最强烈传达出来的是你的热情、你为什么想做这份特定工作的内在驱动力、你的价值观，你知道，不要觉得自己必须无所不知、成为专家。但正如我刚才所说的那样，那种开放性、好奇心和持续学习是非常非常重要的，特别是在培训阶段，我认为。但是，你知道，我真心认为这在整条职业生涯的轨迹中都非常重要。太棒了。这是极好且有用的建议。谢谢。接下来你有什么打算，
Liz? What comes next at this, Yeah, the opposite end of the clinical psychology career. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, I think one of the, there's lots of reasons why I chose to take the opportunity to finish now. But I think one of the main ones is that I've still got some gas left in the tank. I didn't want, you know, I didn't want to end tired or, you know, at the end of my energy levels for the job and thought now was a good time to press pause. I think the cancer diagnosis has obviously brought lots of things into sharp relief and the need to have the summer off and not do very much and just catch up with myself really and what the last year has meant because I've literally just finished you know I had my last consultation with the oncologist last week so I'm very very
莉兹？接下来会发生什么，是的，临床心理学家职业生涯的另一端。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，我认为其中一个原因——我选择现在完成这个职业有许多原因。但我认为其中一个主要原因是我的油箱里还有油。我不想，你知道，我不想在筋疲力尽的时候结束，或者不想在对这份工作的能量耗尽时结束，并且觉得现在是按下暂停键的好时机。我认为癌症的确诊显然让许多事情变得非常清晰，并且需要放个夏天假，不要做太多事情，真正地追赶上自我，明白过去这一年意味着什么，因为我真的刚刚结束，你知道，我上周刚和肿瘤科医生进行了最后一次会诊，所以对于我来说，
new to the end of the journey and I think ironically the end of the journey is the hardest bit because you're out on your own. I think it's terribly reassuring to have anybody prepared to take a look at a lump or a bump or listen to your worry when you're in the medical environment. But it's really tough when you're out the other end of it. And, you know, I'm going to be doing some, I've signed up for a moving forward course, for example, which, you know, helps you with that stage. And, you know, I'm going to be doing some, I've signed up for a moving forward course, for example, which, you know, helps you with that stage. And, you know, obviously, as a psychologist, I know lots of the stuff. But I think to go there as me, having been through cancer and hear it afresh and to look for those little nuggets that I'm sure will be there is's going to be really helpful but also really interesting to be on the other end of that and then I'm just going to see what is the moving forward course
刚刚走到旅程的终点还是非常非常新鲜的。而且我认为具有讽刺意味的是，旅程的终点是最艰难的部分，因为你是孤身一人。我认为在医疗环境中，有任何人愿意花时间检查一个肿块或疙瘩，或者倾听你的担忧，这会让人感到无比安心。但当你走到另一端时，真的非常艰难。而且，你知道，我将要做一些事情，比如我已经报名参加了一个“向前迈进”课程，你知道，它可以帮助你度过那个阶段。而且，你知道，我将要做一些事情，比如我已经报名参加了一个“向前迈进”课程，你知道，它可以帮助你度过那个阶段。而且，你知道，显然作为一个心理学家，我知道很多这方面的知识。但我认为，作为一个经历过癌症的我，以自我的身份去那里，以全新的视角倾听，去寻找那些我确信会存在的金玉良言，这将是非常有帮助的，同时也是一种非常有趣的体验，站在那个阶段的另一端，然后我只是去看看，什么是向前迈进课程？
for cancer patients or for people that are retiring it seems like no oh gosh it could be couldn't it I'm sure there'll be lots and lots of um yeah uh bits that will resonate for both of those stages you know it's a life stage and in fact I had my surgery um the day before my youngest child left home to go to university so I've had a lot of you know big life milestones exactly huge milestones so I think I need that time just to catch up with myself and see, you know, what was that all about? And where am I now? So I'm looking forward to that. So the moving forward specifically for health is that?
是针对癌症患者还是针对退休人员？听起来不——天哪，它难道不可以是吗？我确认为这两个阶段都会有很多很多的嗯，产生共鸣的部分，你知道，这是生命的一个阶段。事实上，我做手术的那天，正是我最小的孩子离家去上大学的前一天，所以我经历了很多，你知道，重大的人生里程碑，确实是巨大的里程碑。所以我想我需要那段清静的时间来好好审视自己，看看，这一切到底是怎么回事？我现在在哪里？所以我非常期待这一点。那么专门针对健康的“向前迈进”课程是怎样的？
It's specifically, sorry, I've not been clear. It's specifically for people who've had a primary breast cancer. So it's kind of designed specifically around that. Although I'm sure, as I I say the general themes will very much resonate yeah and I think you know there's different parallels with the work we do as psychologists as well because of course there's long waiting lists for for mental health as well and then when they're when they're better they're no longer sort of meet our access criteria and so they graduate out of our service then they're like oh but now what I trusted you I like this relationship and it's how we go forwards totally yeah I mean one of the just thinking about um
它专门是，抱歉，我刚才没说清楚。它专门针对患有原发性乳腺癌的人。所以它是专门围绕这个设计的。尽管我相信，就像我说的，总体主题会产生非常多的共鸣，是的。并且我认为，你知道，我们作为心理学家的工作也有不同的相似之处，因为当然，心理健康服务的等待时间也很长，然后当他们康复时，他们不再符合我们的接诊标准，于是他们从我们的服务中“毕业”，然后他们就会说：“噢，可是现在该怎么办？我信任你，我喜欢这种关系。”这关乎我们如何向前发展。完全是这样，是的。我的意思是，其中一个——仅仅考虑到嗯，
our service and how it's developed over the years one of the things I feel most proud about is that we've really challenged that idea of um you need to meet a threshold and then you have your treatment and then you're out model of working with children and families who are experiencing mental health difficulties because it just doesn't fit. It's just, you know, it doesn't fit with their development, which means they're changing all of the time. It doesn't fit with when you need that help at a particular point in time. So we've developed a lot of services and uh you know based on the principle of no wrong door and that's really about empowering all professionals in children's lives to feel more confident and competent to be able to manage things having quick and easy access to expertise so helplines groups, all of those sorts of things, as well as obviously when those things don't work, specific interventions that are evidence based.
我们的服务以及多年来它是如何发展的，我感到最自豪的事情之一就是，我们真正挑战了那种“你需要达到某个门槛，然后接受治疗，接着就出局”的工作模式，这种模式是针对经历心理健康困难的儿童和家庭的，因为它根本不适合。它就是，你知道，它不符合他们的发展规律，这意味着他们一直在变化。它不符合你在特定时间点需要这种帮助的需求。因此，我们开发了许多服务，嗯，你知道，这些服务基于“没有错误的门槛”这一原则，这真正关乎赋能儿童生活中的所有专业人士，让他们感到更有自信和能力去处理事情，能够快速且轻松地获得专业知识，比如帮助热线、小组活动、所有这些类型的事情，当然也包括当这些方法不管用时，提供基于证据的具体干预措施。
But also one of our kind of key hopes is that we've developed services that really empower all professionals to feel confident and competent in this area and it's not a separate thing but actually teachers in school, youth workers, the police, anybody who comes into children and young people feels that they've got a bit of an understanding and demystifying what mental health is so yeah I feel really proud of that aspect of it, that we've really moved away from, you know, waiting times being the thing that determines whether or not you get help or not, and meeting a particular criteria in a particular way at a particular point in time, which is the least helpful thing for children and families, I think. It's the power of upskilling as we go along and
但同时，我们的核心期望之一是，我们开发的服务能够真正赋予所有专业人士在这个领域感到自信和胜任的能力，这不再是一件孤立的事情，而是学校里的老师、青年工作者、警察，任何接触儿童和青少年的人都觉得他们对心理健康有了一点理解并将其去神秘化。所以，是的，我为这一方面感到非常自豪，我们真正摆脱了等待时间成为决定你是否能获得帮助的因素，摆脱了在特定时间点以特定方式满足特定标准的模式，我认为这对于儿童和家庭来说是最没有帮助的事情。这是我们在前行过程中不断提升技能的力量，
the consultancy model isn't it and spreading a little bit of what we know you know far and wide so that it kind of becomes self-perpetuating really. Yeah absolutely and it's not just about knowledge it's about availability as well so I think that you know we know this as psychologists don't we that we can get trained in something and feel confident and competent on that day. And then something will throw us and we'll feel like we've lost that. So I think it's that continuous opportunity to have drop in supervision, consultation, feel that there's somebody at the end of the phone. Just that support that I think we're really privileged in our profession to prioritize but other professions just don't have that and so we're very keen to build that level of support and supervision and advice and consultation
也是咨询模式，不是吗？将我们所知道的一点点知识传播得更远，使其真正成为一种自我延续的过程。是的，绝对是这样。这不仅关乎知识，也关乎可及性。所以我想，作为心理学家我们也很清楚这一点，我们可以接受某项培训，并在当天感到自信和胜任。然后某些事情会让我们不知所措，我们会觉得自己好像失去了那种能力。因此，我认为这是持续获得即兴督导、咨询的机会，让人觉得电话那头有人在支持。这种支持我认为在我们的职业中是我们非常荣幸能够优先考虑的，但其他专业并没有这种支持，所以我们非常渴望将这种水平的支持、督导、建议和咨询，
into every aspect of of children's lives really amazing thank you so much for spending your time one of your first weeks of retired life with us helping guide us through your career and what's been really important and offering your best advice and wishing you the very best with this next stage of your career and may your health continue to be vibrant. Thank you. That's really kind. And it's been an absolute privilege. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much for our guests for today. It was an absolute pleasure speaking with Liz. And I find myself thinking I'd have loved to have been Liz's trainee or Liz's assistant. I feel like I would have really been nurtured really well and guided through the process so I hope that you whoever you're working with have got a good relationship with your supervisors and I hope you found Lizzie's advice
真正融入到儿童生活的方方面面。太棒了，非常感谢你把退休生活最初的几周时间分给我们，帮助指导我们的职业生涯，分享那些真正重要的事情并提供最好的祝愿，祝愿你在职业生涯的下一个阶段一切顺利，愿你的健康常青。谢谢。你太客气了。这绝对是一种荣幸。谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢我们今天的嘉宾。与莉兹交谈绝对是一种享受。我发现自己在想，我也很希望能成为莉兹的实习生或莉兹的助理。我觉得我会被培养得非常好，并在整个过程中得到很好的指导，所以我希望你，无论你在和谁共事，都能和你的主管建立良好的关系，我希望你觉得莉兹的建议
and guidance and wise words really useful I'd love to know what you think to this episode do come along to join me on my socials I'm Dr Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. You can also catch up with me in the Aspiring Psychologist community free Facebook group. I will look forward to delivering the next episode of the podcast, which is available from Monday 6am. Until then, thanks for being part of my world. Take care and be kind to yourself. With this podcast that you'll see, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
以及指导和明智的话语非常有用。我很想知道你对这期节目的看法，快来社交媒体上加入我吧，我在所有地方都是“玛丽安·特伦特博士”（Dr. Marianne Trent）。你也可以在“有志心理学家社区”免费Facebook小组中找到我。我期待着推出播客的下一期节目，该节目将于周一上午6点发布。在此之前，感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重，善待自己。通过这个你将看到的播客，你将走上获得资质的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名心理健康实习从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。达到这个目标有多少不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，觉得自己并没有做错，并减少了给自己的压力。因此，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但是相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。